we are waiting on the president's fake
news awards as his relations with the
press are more contentious than ever mr.
president did you say that you want more
people to come in from Norway did you
say that you wanted more cake is that
true miss very much everywhere
everywhere thank you very much everybody
just just Caucasian or white country sir
do you want people to come in from other
parts of the world where they're people
of color we're not sure what to expect
but some things planned and we're gonna
keep an eye on that
now some members of the president
president Trump's own party are taking
him to task for attacks on the press
John McCain wrote an op-ed in the
Washington Post and Jeff Flake delivered
this rebuke on the Senate floor the
enemy of the people was how the
President of the United States called
the Free Press in 2017 mr. president it
is a testament to the condition of our
democracy that our own president uses
words infamously spoken by Joseph Stalin
to describe his enemies when a figure in
power reflexively calls any press that
doesn't suit him fake news it is that
person who should be the figure of
suspicion not the press 2018 must be the
year in which the truth takes a stand
against power that would weaken it let
us resolve to be allies of the truth and
not partners in its destruction the
White House had this to say about the
senator speech I found it quite
interesting that he is coming out to
attack this president considering he's
one that was recently defending an
actually oppressive regime he went to
Cuba a few weeks ago and served as a
mouthpiece for the oppressive Cuban
government he's not criticizing the
president because he's against
oppression he's criticizing the
president because he has terrible poll
numbers and he is I think looking for
some attention looking for some
attention Greg yeah I think the ultimate
relate yes I can't the ultimate joke by
Donald Trump could be that the fake news
awards is fake news and it never happens
just that's a nice practical joke
here's the problem with flake and that I
call that flake news is that he's
comparing a tyrant Stalin to the
president of a republic so it's a little
bit different I would say it's it's
dishonest it's in it it's hyperbole you
can criticize the press in America in
fact deflate kind of worried me when he
said that the only objective truth was
in the media which is just nuts if the
media would admit its bias then
accusations of false news would actually
fade
it's the biggest lie of all the deny
that reporters are not clouded by their
own confirmation bias we know it it
happens here it happens there so you
have no right to criticize anybody for
criticizing the media because it's not
it's not about lies it's about shaping
your story based on bias and the other
the other flaw in in flakes reasoning
and this is done for attention like
flake news is that Trump is bad for the
press it is no one has ever been better
for the press in the history yesterday's
medical press conference he wouldn't let
the doctor go back inside till he
answered every question he for eight
years they were Obama toast you know
they were in a coma under Obama because
they agreed with everything that Obama
did because they can't stay in Trump
they suddenly I mean it daily gave him a
trick they gave him I think Trump gave
them a liver transplant
they're now alive and they're mad no
they should be they should be bowing
before Trump for actually bringing them
back to life he really is like an organ
transplant for the press it's so true
okay so he's revitalizing so Katie what
did you make of it well I got off of
Greg's point and say that the White
House press corps has ever been so
interesting I mean we play live the
briefings every single day and the
reporters who sit in that room who never
used to get any kind of TV attention are
now getting attention but back to Jeff
Lakes floor speech the first thing is if
he's really so concerned about
protecting the First Amendment
protecting the press and why is he
bowing out early instead of standing and
fighting keeping his seat in Arizona and
then taking it to the president in a
position of power instead he's rolling
over and
you know doing this on his last stand
and then what he said just wasn't true
he specifically said that this has never
happened before this kind of attack is
unprecedented politicians whether you're
the President or Congress have always
had a precarious relationship that's the
whole point of having a free independent
press and the government that is held
accountable so they're always going to
deal with this we're gonna see this for
the next three years definitely the next
seven if President Trump skits gets
reelected they need each other Trump
likes the attention whether it's good or
bad and the press certainly likes the
attention especially those in the White
House press corps mm-hmm okay Jess we'll
just talk about Acosta for a second I
respect him but he's a total drama queen
if correspondent had treated President
Obama like that he would have thrown him
in Gitmo that was very disrespectful and
flake a noble statesman but just totally
out of control
Stalin killed 20 million people Trump
the only people he's been killing has
been Isis and you can criticize like you
said the press it doesn't mean you're
attacking the First Amendment fake news
is the enemy of the Republican Party
president Trump's the only Republican
that's actually said it he's been
incredibly open he just did a 40 minute
on the record interview with the New
York Times at Marla ah just walking by
also did another on the record interview
with The Wall Street Journal just spoke
to Reuters for 45 minutes his own doctor
told us things we didn't really want to
know our in the press corps it was
incredibly transparent and you juxtapose
that to President Obama who put more
whistleblowers in jail than anybody else
prosecuted them had Hillary Clinton
tying up reporters in ropes I remember
that never even went on Fox News was
terrified and I didn't hear a lot of
people saying oh you know President
Obama's and Curt encouraging other
leaders across the globe to crack down
when President Obama was using the IRS
to crack down on political opponents I
didn't hear Jeff Flake saying oh he's
inspiring the world leaders to crack
down on their political opponents it's
baloney yeah you know it's a it's
baloney that's apparently being cut by
Republicans because it's not only Jeff
Flake it's John McCain today on the
op-ed page of The Washington Post saying
that the president's rhetoric the way
that he talks about the press the enemy
of the American people again picking up
on what flake said about that ving
stalinistic language is a threat to
press freedoms not only in this country
but a bad example for people in the
Philippines and other countries where
you know reporters face intimidation
harassment and the truth the truth is
constantly being suppressed his
leadership in the world isn't that what
they were saying
now listen he's leading other leaders to
crack down on the press [ __ ] down start
when Trump got elected or no I think the
United States of America a country with
the First Amendment protections for the
press should not be giving any comfort
or support to autocrats around the world
who are seeking to suppress the press
but that's what this president is doing
I mean trouble whatever aggressive going
after Venezuela
he's pretty aggressive slamming CNN
remember that one oh I forgot about it
I think he delighted in this he
delighted what's wrong with that so
delighting in a joke I'm weirded a
period now where if you delight in a
joke somehow you're setting a bad
example for other countries how about
this Trump to get the Lifetime
Achievement Award for fake news oh but
what the birther movement Obamacare is
dead right remember that how about Obama
let's waste wiretapping Trump Tower
remember that actually proven it's not
true how about this one crowd ever how
about this one landslide I won in a
landslide biggest ever healthcare
playing economic growth coming any
minute he says I'm looking
we're getting plus three percent maybe
three months 2005 I'm okay with that
yeah I'm just saying this guy makes up
more stuff and he should be crowned the
fountainhead abatement maybe that's what
he'll do Wanda fact is the fact is you
know what we know what Trump is he
doesn't actually hide what Trump is he's
more see-through than the guy in
operation a little dude you can pull out
the organs you know what everything what
you get and I don't even you know
America kind of accepts that it's the
media that doesn't accept no but the
media doesn't accept a fundamental truth
that we all know that they are clouded
by confirmation bias we see it
everywhere I will admit that it happens
to me but the media gets up in arms when
you just point out the obvious fact he's
not saying the First Amendment sucks
he's saying that he's tired of stories
being shaped by confirmation bias that's
all it is everybody you say you say
there's confirmation by say but you know
what they're people they're working
journalists right try to tell you
exactly when he when he lies about
having said [ __ ] yeah but you know
who makes makes good journalists who are
doing good work who are putting out the
facts look look really bad people like
Jim Acosta who go into the Oval Office
ask a legitimate question about the
kinds of people that President Trump
wants to come here he answers the
question and says everybody right and
Jim Acosta follows up with a loaded
racial question about only white people
being able to come that's the plot is
the problem that's a problem when in
fact that's what you were thinking
because the question we asked a
follow-up loaded question Trump told him
to get out just like Obama would get out
but and then he follows up on Twitter as
the victim and says I never thought this
would happen to me in America yes he
said in America as though there are
other countries that are bad Jim Acosta
as a correspondent in the Oval Office
should be an adversarial force
questioning a non-biased material forces
when President Obama was
questions I remember what's the most
enchanting you're saying to me you don't
think that President Obama who was
excoriated by this network for Obamacare
got any easy treatment we can't blame us
for Obamacare people that have escaped
the USSR when they here who are here now
and old enough to remember how bad it
was there when they hear somebody like
flake make that comparison I've run into
Russians who look at Trump as as a
symbol of capitalism something that
actually works you've run into Russians
I know believe we disavow